Film Courage: Dan what about the writer who
is too loose, too sloppy, doesn’t check
everything out “Oh everything is going to
be fine.”
Because they are almost like two of the same?
Daniel Calvisi, movie studio reader, screenwriter
and private screenplay consultant: …Two
sides of the same coin?
Well, that’s where a consultant like me
can really help you?
[Gives example of a critique] Okay this is
not a professional level quality.
I was confused in places.
I really felt like scenes went on too long.
I felt like these voices weren’t authentic
in dialogue.
So I’m the kind of person, a writing coach,
a story consultant who can really help someone
like that and guide them to improve their
craft.
Film Courage: So both of those traits - perfectionist
versus loose non-detail oriented, where does
that stem from?
Dan: Where you fall on the spectrum?
Film Courage: No…I’m wondering how does
someone become a perfectionist?
How does someone become sort of loose kinda
of…
Dan: Kind of a lazy writer?
Film Courage: I’m not sure if it’s so
much lazy but they don’t seem to care as
much about details because they think they
don’t matter.
Maybe they are willing to spend time on stuff
that does matter so they are not lazy in that
respect.
But in terms of tying up loose ends “Ah…they’ll
understand.”
There are just some people that flow with
some things in some ways and are more controlled
in other ways.
Where does that come from?
Dan: Well I think it comes from your personality.
I think it comes from your own personal experience,
how you approach creative work.
But it is a craft and it’s going to take
a long time to learn that craft and really
perfect it and to write your best work, to
find your voice and write the best thing that
you were born to write and it’s going to
take time and if you are really loose and
what you might call lazy just you’re not
detail-oriented, you’re not specific, you
just don’t care if the scene is confusing
because it makes sense to you.
Well that’s going to be a problem because
the reader cares.
Because the reader wants it to makes sense
and wants it to be tight and wants it to have
a really great arc and surprise and subvert
their expectations and wants it to just be
great.
So if you are a really loose writer then maybe
screenwriting is not quite the discipline
for you.
Film Courage: Sure.
Then the flip side of one that can’t let
it go because there are just too many variables
that they’ve got to make sure are right
but then the life is squeezed out because
it’s so tight.
Dan: It can become dryer the more you pick
at it and pick at it.
I can’t say specifically which draft does
that happen.
Okay, between draft 12 and 15 it’s going
to get way too dry and you’re going to lose
that original essence.
But that is that instance in which someone
picks at something and picks at something,
rewrites it so many times, takes every single
note they get from every friend and every
consultant and it ends up just kind of bleeding
it dry and you lose the essence of the original
idea, the original concept what made you passionate
about that.
That’s a pitfall too to look out for.